So, we can use it for the, yeah, for five days actually, so that was...
Home.
Yeah.
Bad timing, let's just say bad timing.
Keeping on top of everything.
Yep, yep, so I hope it is restored now.
Understandable.
As we start now, yeah, so, and all of us is now trying to get our our month end out of the way.
Okay, that's great. I got to know this from Sally, who could not log into her RDP server because the quick looks were down and I guess there was some incidence also ongoing. So, but I guess Krishna was able to log in from her side.
Yes, yes.
That's right, yeah.
Ohh.
Yep, yep, that's right.
Yeah, take care. Yeah, thank you for helping with helping us with that.
Is Sally, sorry, is Sophia joining in?
I do so.
Hi, Tanim.
Laroia.
Good.
How are you doing?
Little nuts here, but just it's our month end and and our year end, so April 3rd, so it's and plus we had one week of issue with the QuickBooks that no one could could could use, so it it crashed for that one. Well, I think one week concluded the weekend, so it's five days.
Ha ha.
Yeah.
Sir.
Yeah, it's a bad time to crash, right? It's A year-end, yeah.
Exactly.
That's right.
Shall we wait for?
So if you had to join or...
Let's see, we should.
But.
Once again, let me see if you can buzzer.
Let's see, Sofia, she is.
Okay, she has away status, so I'm not sure.
Yeah, put a tag on the chat, Ashish and see if she is able to see.
Yep, I'm doing it.
Okay.
What do you want to do? Way more to start without her.
Yep, she's showing away.
Yeah, sure is a way.
And.
So, it's 12:30 on her time, 12:30 P.m.
Yeah, we are 4 minutes in. I think we should get started.
Yeah, so.
Okay.
All right. So thank you so much, Tanim, for joining this call. And I would like to start with feedback about Krishna, how she is doing.
Okay, so as mentioned, we did lose QuickBooks for five days, so she couldn't do as much, but she did clean up a lot in the vendor board. Cleaning in a sense, I don't mean by, oh no, she did, she did.
She did her little clean up in the vendor board, which I mean, I didn't expect her to sit idling when Cripple was down, so she caught her in the vendor board. She did clean up a bit.
So last couple of days, I did take her away from the vendor board. I needed her help with the payments. In the past, Ray was doing the payments with Krishna.
All right.
So I spent time with her, so I, because I haven't done the AP payments.
I went with her to list for two hours. Just it was a lot of invoices. I need to explain it. Who is this vendor? Why are we paying them? Why are we paying them? Who are we paying them? So she tried to answer. She knew the answer, so I was happy about that.
But issuing payments, it does take a little bit longer than normal. So that's my little complaint. Like there were several vendors that we had to pay on Thursday and basically it took an entire day. I don't think it should take an entire day to issue payments.
Um, so that maybe...
Um...
Again, I don't know, this is my first time, like I said, this is my first time with her doing AP payments, but I mean, I could be, maybe I'm just being too hard on her, so.
That's my opinion.
I don't think it should take her that long to do it, in my opinion.
And, Tanim, thank you for the feedback. Is there an impact?
If the payment is expected to be done today and is done today, but if there is, of course, there is a change of speed, right, when we move from one person to other, right? So eventually, do you see that as an impact on the customer or is it just that she?
No, this is the impact of the person who two people that approve the payments.
I mean, she schedules that Kris and I will go through this on Wednesday. It did, like I said, it took us two hours because I was new at it. So I was being thrilled with the list. And Kris provided good answers of each of the questions I've asked. And then on Thursday, she went
the process of issuing the payment, applying the payment in QuickBooks, also applying the payment in Deja Javid, but it took her an entire day. I don't think it should take an entire day.
That again, I don't know what she was doing in between. Maybe she had some other tasks and maybe she was distracted. I don't know, but to me it took her entire day and by 5:00 she was done and she sent a report on like Thursday night to the to the approval.
Like Friday morning, so Friday morning, I mean, she got done on time, but took her entire day. I don't think she took her entire day.
That's what I'm trying to say. I don't think I should.
Let me, let me share my screen. I have a great snapshot of Krishna's work for the past week.
So, that windows, you're able to see it.
Sure, OK.
I don't know where she put the list. I forgot where she put the list. So I could just figure out how many vendors that she needs to issue payments. So okay.
You.
Yep, so what Krishna did was she worked on 81 when the tickets during this period. So this is from just a second.
Just give me a minute.
Right. This is from April 30th till May 6th. And in this duration, Krishna was closed on 81 when the tickets. Other than that, she handled 13 work cases and follow up with vendors regarding bank information and related updates. Although
QuickBooks server was down, but May 6th was the peak day where she worked on 31 vendor board items which were closed by her. Other than that, there were 18 vendor board items were closed, including a large block of LCM invoice to the client.
and link to Azure on May 5th. So I hope you have visibility to this information or is it something that...
No, yeah, no, I...
She did discuss about that she didn't close enough tickets. I told don't worry about it. Just because I spent time with you with like the AP payments. So I mentioned that don't worry about that because I took you away from the vendor board. So that's understandable if the closure of the tickets were lower than that we agreed upon. So it's okay. I'm okay with that.
I.
Yeah, the trend, yes, I'm fine with the trend, yes.
Okay, do you have any concerns with the way she worked in the past week by looking at this information?
Uh, well, Megan, this is my... Well, um...
I'm okay. Was there my first week?
with the payments. So that's my first week with her. So next week we'll see how it goes. So I guess she knows my expectation from her for the payments, but my expectation is different from Ray. So she's learning like my new process, the presentation so that when
Manu gets the payment that she, this is, I think you should do this so that Manu could see everything on one screen as having already search invoices to payments. So I hope, so let's give her an idea of how she should.
Maybe if it's a different approach, if it works or not work. So, but the way I see it is that she just she agreed upon that the new process.
But if she doesn't agree, then maybe she won't say in front of me, maybe she'll say it to you guys, so I need to know as well. So if she doesn't, okay.
Vaid.
Absolutely, yep.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, Amy, for sharing that. And just one quick update. I hope you're aware that next week Krishna is out. She's on plan leave from 11th till 15th. And on a similar lines, I wanted to ask you because I reached out to you and Sophia regarding the upcoming holiday for May 18th and 25th.
Yes.
So, Sophia was aligned with letting Sally take it off on 18th. However, you said that it will be 25th for Krishna. So...
Yeah.
I'm flexible, like if Krishna wants it under 18 or 25th, I'm doesn't matter, doesn't, it's okay, I'm okay, other dates. It's whatever Krishna would like, just give me a heads up.
Popkin.
Yeah, because I think you guys are also on off on 18.
We are off the 18th, yes.
Yep, so even if Krishna logs in the information that she would need with customers and follow-ups, she would not be able to reach anyone because it's an off there. So she being logged in on the 18th would be of less fruitful as compared to she logs in on the 25th.
Sure, that's fine. Okay, that's fine.
Thank you so much. So I'll cascade this information. And I'll also ensure Krishna to put her out of office in the calendar and connect with Management so that the entire team is aware that she's not available for the next week.
Okay.
Okay, yep. That's about it. Any other questions or suggestions, Tanim, you have?
I mean, I'm so...
Since Ray left and I worked closely with her, I just want to make sure that if she has any feedback about my performance with her, if she's open with you guys, I'd like to know if I have any faults. Does something that she's not comfortable or she's upset about that, I'd like to know if I could change.
My attitude towards her, like, I, I like Kris not a lot, I really do.
Yes.
We appreciate it. And Tammy, there is, she is not disappointed with you at all. Let me just clear that. So you are approachable as per her. She says that whenever she has any questions, she gets out to you and get all the, all get her questions answered. So yeah, I think you are doing a pretty good job there and thank you so much for your support.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, thank you. Okay.
Yep.
All right, this is this. And I wanted to know, since array is not available anymore, so I think you have a lot to do on your plate. So how are you managing it?
I do, yes. Right now, it is split between me and Ehmen, so she's taking some of his responsibility, and I will take, and I have taken some as well. But, yes.
The.
Just.
So far, it's again, with the QuickBook being down, it's a bad timing, so I, yeah.
Yeah.
I get it.
especially during the time of the year when it was needed the most.
Yes, yeah, exactly, yes.
Okay, I guess I'm on done from my site. Amit sir, do you have anything to add?
No, I think we really wanted to have some connect with Sophia as well to understand how Sally is doing, given that there were, we had the feedback that she was moving in the right direction, she was doing well, but at the same time, it was mentioned that there were certain areas that she needed to improve.
Okay.
We also had a plan that we wanted to discuss. We call it as a service improvement plan. So that's a formal way of tracking, right, the improvement areas. But yeah, Sophia is not here. So yeah, I don't know, Tanim, if you get to speak with her at all, if you can please let us know that, you know, we would really want to have a connect with her.
whenever she's available, even before next week. Even if we have to do a 15 minutes meeting on Monday, that'll help us align, right, and make sure that Sally is moving in the right direction. Rest, I think I'm good.
Okay.
Maybe we'll just, if I do reach out to her, she can make a small comment in the group chat. And if she wants to reach out to you like on a different time with you guys, and I'll let her know that too as well.
Yeah, even that will do.
Great. Sarbjeet, anything you want to add?
Key.
No, Ashish, thank you. You and Amit have already covered everything. The only thing which I just like to add in here, Tammy, anything or any day whenever you think that things are not moving as per your expectations, you don't have to wait for these service calls. Me, Ashish, Amit, all of us are just a text away. The Team Federation is active, so you can always ping us on the Team channel.
We love to connect with you accordingly.
Okay, yeah.
All right, with that being said, Tammy will call it a meeting and I will share this presentation deck in the email and I will ask Krishna to update her out of office for the next week and 18th would be the holiday for Krishna as well.
Okay.
Oh, sure, that's fine. Yeah, I'm, I'm, I thought if you wanted a holiday for line with your holiday, that's why I thought, but it's up to you guys. I'm doesn't matter to me.
Thank you so much, Tanim. All right, so we'll see you next week. Until then, have a great weekend.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, yeah, thank you. Okay, bye.
Take care, Tanim. Have a good one.
Bye bye.
Thank you, Tanim.